Sunburned tomato here.
(That's a nice face)
How's it going? Everyone?
That's right. I go outside for five minutes.
Badinga. (it's Bazinga pewds..)
And I'm back in, everybody.
Where I belong.
You know, wherever I talk to people online
that maybe don't know who I am.
I'm always hit with the-
Pfft (high-mid pitch voice) That happened.
Yeah, that totally happened.
Sure right you met that person.
Yeah, I did guys,
It's me,
It's me guys, it's PewDiePie. (Soft voice)
Why don't you believe me?
😭😭😭
When it turns out the reason why people treat me with such indignity,
such disrespect,
It's because there's a reddit it's based on disputing these sort of claims.
Okay?
I am PewDiePie.
I promise.
Stop.
So let's review some of the top ones on That Totally Happened.
You and me, together.
(EXPLOSION)
Smash like.
I went to Walmart
to buy a tube of cookie dough and a box of tampon and as a
17 year old boy was ringing up my stuff
He just looked at me and said it's going to be okay reply and just after that
He said by the way, I'm 17 years old
I wanted you to know that so you can describe me in your fake text post on tumblr
Bazinga, that's right. How could you possibly know that she was - he was 17. Hmm. I feel like tumblers do this
Especially I kind of get it now it took me one post and I mean it's easy
We're just supposed to take everything at face value
No, no, not me. I'm an intellectual eyebrows. Read it occasionally
I was in the bank with my five-year-old sister when we hear everyone get down
we all got down except my sister who say
Stealing is wrong
I can already tell this is gonna be great
The robbers bolted out and everyone stood and clapped the bank manager gave us
1000 pounds for saving the day as well laughing crying emoji laughing crying emoji laughing crying emoji
Could this be a whoosh you know, this is obviously fake on purpose right? You got faker Deckard?
I love these these verified Twitter tweets
Everyone dies one day everyone even bulls but not books
Not words. What don't die my son three who is a lot smarter than I am
It must be so great to have a fictional three-year-old. You don't have to even change the diapers.
Awesome. It's like, oh I have this somewhat decent tweet. What if I credit it to my three-year-old then it would be amazing.
This is actually our quit your bullsh*t.
But you know, you know.
You know is true if you started it off with "literally". They literally banned camo pants from my old school because,
people kept making invisible jokes and one teacher had a mental breakdown and decided to quit because of them.
That's right. A teacher,
decided to quit school because people just kept making camouflage jokes.
I understand, that's- that's what drives a teacher over the edge.
My English teacher wrote part of a poem I wrote on the board today,
which honestly surprised me. She had the student guess who wrote it and most of the answers were the President or
Shakespeare. When my teacher revealed that it was I who wrote it,
I received an applause and then the President himself came out and congratulates me,
and Shakespeare rose from the dead and say "Well done to thee". I have never lied in my entire life.
This would never happen to me. You'll never see PewDiePie on this board.
Teacher: I want everyone to write down the people that inspire you the most. Teacher walks over and looks at my paper.
Who are these gentlemen with colored hair? They're youtubers. They're not really inspirational people dear.
They just sit around at home and talk to camera all day meet teacher you just stand around
And talk to kids that aren't even paying attention to you all day
Continued writing youtubers names
Here's another PewDiePie one I pull down my pants and press them against the monitor
then my mom walked in and I was like
Mom don't look at me Peter pie told me to really what you should have said is mom look at me
That totally happened while shopping at in Target. I heard a girl say boys are so dumb
to which I replied say it louder to the girls in the back to which she screamed boys are so dumb - which other
customers replied with a slow clap best
target experience
Yet boys are so dumb. Can this video hit?
5,000 likes boys are so dumb if she said women are so dumb boy
Don't even make me comment about the hypocrisy lib tardes you wouldn't even care. Would you pathetic? Oh
My god, I asked this girl in my class for a piece of gum
every day for the whole semester
today was our last day and I asked her for a gum and she gave me the whole pack as a
Parting gift if it ain't the smoothness thing I have ever seen
So she wrote her number on each piece of the gum number one
How will you know the order of them number two that didn't happen? You're a virgin?
Similar thing happened to me the other night
My cab driver had my life by $0.50 and Eminem on and asked me if I wanted to change it to
Country I responded by wrapping the rest of the song word for word. Then the taxi clad
Even if that happened, it's just cringy. Alright don't care if it happened. How about that? How about
Sided subreddit for you
If I lose this bet I'll eat my hat physics teacher who proceeded to lose the bet take his hat
Dissolve it in acid
neutralize it with a base making it water pour the mixture into his coffee and down it in one cup that most
Certainly happened as one teacher does of course. Oh
Not a problem for me to eat his hat. I'll just dissolve it in acid and neutralize it with the face making it
Hmm why do people bother why do people bother okay so like I'm sleepy as hell
Lmao I thought I put on my work shoes walked out of the house like damn
My feet cold as hell of course, of course
Who doesn't lace their shoe on the outside and not notice it on both feet, of course, of course that happens
my high school had such a large population of emos that when my
MCR broke up. They announced it via the PA and
offered extra
Counseling that day, how about our if it's true, you're all a bunch of pussy boys. How about that?
Is that a good subreddit?
I was at Dunkin Donuts and asked for three donuts and a water cup the entire staff
Thought I said three donuts in a water cup. Here's a result can't make this
Yes, you can stop lying. I'm sick of your lies. That didn't happen
Did it say it say it you dumped those doughnuts? You put those doughnuts in that water? No one else stop it
get some help my gender studies professor told me to go to Subway and snap a picture of
A male worker making me a sandwich as extra cred hashtag
patriarchy
It's funny because gender studies degree only legitimately qualifies you for a job at Subway
There's no shame in making the sandwich tonight at the gym a man
Looks like a thing Thor go ask me out when I told him I was a lesbo he goes
Oh, chill, you know my sister and I work out a lot together
She'll be here tomorrow same time
Like did door just wingman me god of lesbos. We have found the picture of Thor
This is what he looked like this did actually in fact happen. What an incredible story
This is why I hate stories, and I hate telling them because
I don't believe myself even telling a story and I most suddenly don't believe other people.
Yes.
Hope you guys had a great Thanksgiving
Me actually, I don't find it fun to celebrate genocide and colonization. So I spent this
Thanksgiving blogging and
Protesting, but thanks. How was yours? The class just claps...
They're all just clapping...
FINALLY. *clapping*
FINALLY SOMEONE SAID IT.
FINALLY SOMEONE SAID IT. THANK YOU.
Actually, I was a teacher. It was incredible and then she did a backflip.
I left a six-figure job at NASA to have
no responsibilities working as a cook at
McDonald's. Not kidding happiest I've ever been. Oh, and is your name Kevin Spacey?
And do you live in the American Beauty universe? Is that what happened?
You did steak stories from movies and apply them to your own thing?
Is that it? Pathetic. Not even McDonald's want you, okay? Over at WcDonald's though, we're hiring guys.
Check out new merch. Link in the description.
I purchased a plane ticket online and went to the effing Airport and got on an effing plane and now I'm in Sweden
Drunk me is an effing mental case, help. This is actually true. That was me.
I was traveling home to see my parents and I got confused.
This actually totally happened. I feel like the reason why these posts appear so frequently online is because
Face-to-face, you know I can tell when people are lying. I'm pretty good at it.
I think most people can tell when someone's lying. We don't really want to confront people face-to-face.
You won't really necessarily- it's easier to just go "Wow, what a cool story" instead of going...
I don't believe that happened.
Unless it's someone I know very closely like, if my neighbor is just small talking with me, telling me some story
I'm not just gonna call them out be like "Yeah, no".
"You're full of sh*t."
And I think that's why so often on Facebook people just post whatever, because they're so used to getting away with these lies.
So, it's an interesting phenomena. What do you guys think? Let me know in the comments.
Tell me a story that it definitely happened to you. I'd be very interested to hear about it. Thank you for watching this video.
Leave a like if you enjoyed check out the March guys. I really appreciate the support so far has been amazing
This has been pity pie. Bye.